[Music]
police call - tori spelling's Woodland
Hills home early Thursday
the LAPD confirms the et that they
responded to a disturbance call around
7:15 a.m. ET obtained audio of the
dispatch call all right no word on who
made the 9-1-1 call but on wednesday the
mother of five was hanging out with
former bachelor contestant corinne
elympios who shared this video of an
item to a no alum this is so epic right
now Tori Spelling everybody
she tells ET they hung out for about an
hour to film a Facebook digital show
corinne says Tori seemed a little tired
and like her mind was somewhere else at
one point she made a joke about wanting
to extend the hangout so that her hubby
would take care of their baby a little
bit longer
last year Tori opened up to ET about
balancing five kids with Dean I'm
definitely way outnumbered like I always
am like I can do it I can do everything
and then I'm like oh my gosh Dean I need
help like someone carry the baby
Edie we'll continue monitoring the story
as it develops
[Music]